hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einer weiteren
folge nintendo organisiert sind hier mal
wieder zusammen mit dem kleinen ball und
da kommt auch schon lange klar wieso war
da gerade eine fliege wieso ist eine fik
um sein kopf warum wir schauen erst mal
wie es dem kleinen ball ohne geht und
zwar ist bauermann gott x-trackers
erfahrungen gemacht du kleiner dann
kriegte er erstmal einen tollen pöppel
trockenfutter und dann gebe ich dir auch
sofort war mal ein bisschen fast alle
kleider und dann frisst nicht mehr was
oder wie das ist doch ein richtiger balu
da steht die hungern und dann etwas zu
essen und dann ist er erst nicht mal ist
der denn dumm das ist ein typischer balu
aha da selbst können wir den nicht rein
theoretisch neben anstupsen ich glaube
essen steht bei ihm hat aber alles und
dann geht man jetzt auch noch mal eben
bisschen gewaschen weil er ja
unglaublich dreckig war mein gott ist
sehr dreckig alter im vergleich zum
letzten mal seine kleinen bläschen da
kommt viel dreck
das erst mal schön abspülen und dann
machen wir danach doch mal rein
theoretisch wir können ja eigentlich
noch mal kurz drüber gehen oder das
liegt auch schon mal ein bisschen
sauberer aus kleiner ball nochmal schön
mit dem wasserhahn drüber und dann bist
du gleich wieder wie neu geborener und
du das ist nicht wahr
da steht noch immer nicht dass der
komplett sauber ich glaube ich weiß
woran das liegt sonst habe ich auch mein
gott wie der tisch wackelt wenn ich hier
den hunden putzen bin sonst hatte ich
immer einen state abgespeichert bei
diesen emulator und jetzt habe ich
einfach mal so weitergespielt weil sagte
yao
traurig glaube ich nicht und deswegen
ist jetzt habe ich auch dreckig und aber
jemand sieht jetzt wunderschön auch
dabei lumen sauber ist kann mir rein
theoretisch mal eben einen spaziergang
machen weil mir wurde gesagt dass ich im
park trainieren kann
für die wettbewerbe ich weiß man nicht
wo hier im park ist aber wir gehen
einfach mal hier den weg damit wir hier
was bekommen dann gehen wir
wie kann ich denn in seinem park rhein
ich habe die route jetzt an zwei parks
vorbei gezeichnet also wenn wir da jetzt
nicht trainieren können
du dummkopf dem ich will weiter mit dir
jetzt man bald wieder etwas gefunden und
zwar ist wie so finster keine anderen
hunde hält eine einwegkamera scheint
kaputt zu sein
so freut sich über so einen schwachsinn
mir haben viele gesagt dass es
eigentlich gut ist dass balu auf diesem
wege
wir haben viele geschrieben dass es gut
ist dass wir auf diesen wegen pinkelt
weil sonst meine wohnung pinkeln oder
hole ich glaub ich hab alles größer
gezogen ja ich hoffe das passt jetzt
wieder von der größeren 1
das könnt ihr mir nicht erzählen dass
ein hund auf 100 metern drei mal pinkeln
muss er hat etwas gefunden und zwar
schon wieder nur geschenke erhält eine
einwegkamera seien kaputt zu sein
balu viermal neuer rekord können wir
nicht irgendwo in unserem park gehen wo
wir so ein bisschen trainieren weil ich
habe überhaupt keine ahnung wie man in
den park gehen kann
wie kann das sein bruder kann ich
irgendwie auf wettkämpfe und dann auf
training oder auf irgendwas gehen ach
guck mal ich kann die sogar jetzt meinen
namen hier ändern
dies ist das denn dort trainer ist jetzt
luca das aber jetzt bestätigt und bild
haben wir immer so eine alte
verschrumpelte frau einfach mal
geburtstags eingerichtet unternehmen wir
als status einfach mal hallo mein name
ist luca das passt sogar perfekt hinein
klicken oder auf bestätigen und wir
haben 97 trainer punkte das ist zurzeit
gar nichts freunde habe ich auch keine
wie immer kommt gerade erst von einem
spaziergang gönne deinem hund etwas ruhe
bevor du wieder mit dem spazieren ist er
hatte eine woche lang ruhe schauen 900
aber die kosten alle über 500 euro und
dann komme ich dann wenn ich hinterher
mit einem 450 groschen da nochmal ich
kann die mittel mit anderen hunden auch
irgendwie spielen man die tasten
dieser hund wird perfekt zu passen mit
seiner art schon wieder
gott das was wir hier die ganze zeit was
ist das für ein und wir müssen einfach
mal so ein bisschen trainieren gehen
aber ich habe überhaupt keine ahnung wo
ich irgendwie kann ich zwar eine disc
kaufen oder gummi burst oder comic con
anima die bürste kaufen was man damit
machen soll aber es wird zu teuer wer
musik geht nicht schaut mal wir können
mit seifenblasen okay kann man doch
nichts mit combo fang
korrekt machen danke nice bald mir mal
bitte in die kommentare ob irgendwelche
hacks für dieses spiel kennen oder
irgendeine möglichkeit wie wir in den
park gehen können um trainieren zu gehen
oder ob die irgendwie geld geld
verdienen oder wie ich den beibringt
habe dass wir disc spielen wurden dann
war's auch schon
damit die neuen jetzt ist er hier auch
noch runter gefallen dann war's das auch
schon mit dieser episode wenn es euch
gefallen hat würde mir die vielen die
wir zu einer bewertung freundin für ihn
sonst meint er